[Music]
so do you think your garden might need a
little boost this spring one of the best
ways to tell is to do a soil test a soil
test will tell you what nutrients you
may need in the garden and how much the
spring is the best time to do a soil
test before you add any fertilizer the
tools you'll need will be a
Trel a screwdriver or a similar tool a
clean bucket and some and a bag to put
the sample in a Ziploc bag would be fine
or a paper bag sometimes the soil labs
will provide you a container to use to
collect a sample you'll take the trowel
and put it into the ground to loosen the
soil you'll then use the trowel to
collect a thin slice of soil the goal is
to have a narrow strip of soil down the
center of the trowel so the screwdriver
is a useful tool to help clean up the
edges ideally you will sample to a depth
of about 6 in and you'll put that in
your
bucket then you'll repeat that step
about 10 times for your garden to get a
good composite sample once you've
collected your 10 samples from across
the garden you will mix them thoroughly
in the bucket and then you will collect
about two
cups of this soil into your sample bag
the lab will provide you with a form to
fill out which includes the type of soil
analysis that you would like to have
done and that what you'll be growing in
your garden your local County Extension
Office can help you choose a soil
analysis lab and they can also help you
interpret the results with University of
Wyoming extension I'm Caitlyn youngquist
and you're watching touching from the
ground up
[Music]